[Music]
for the new students my name is vitaly
namer and i'm the game master just up
for the next three weeks I already said
before the time from Russia and hence my
my accent in Russia we really like to
play chess as in the United States your
the question about me all right what's
your question my rating is almost 2400
right now it's about 20 350 a 2400 s how
much you need to be in order to become
an international master
so usually chess players they start
around 600 every time you win a game you
get you gain around 5 to 10 points
depends all you're playing against ok so
it took me a long time to become an
international master about 10 to 15
years so it's a journey it's not not so
easy but it's definitely attainable ok
ok so we are today this is our second
class for today for the more advanced
students right so in the first lesson we
learned about the opening principles
right we learn about the center will
learn about developing the pieces we
learned about and casting ok defending
your king so today I would like to show
you some opening traps okay how to set
up a trap for your opponent in the
opening because if you beat them in your
opening you don't have to suffer for so
long okay you can beat them very very
fast sounds good alrighty so here's our
first our first trap for today first of
all probably most of you are playing
against your parents I am probably
playing against your siblings and in
school as well right and I don't know
what about you but I always experienced
is to say in school that I play chess
and somebody would come up to me and say
I also know how to play chess and then
once you start playing as against
against him you you realize that they
have no idea how to move right but what
happens is is that they try to make the
same moves as you do so they copy Kent
so today our first lesson is going to
I'm going to show you how to punish
those copycats let's say that you are
playing white and real we already said
that our first move is going to be pawn
to e4 and let's say black is making the
same move knob that doesn't have any
idea how to play but he's just going to
copy it for me okay
now the second move that we say that why
it should do is to put the knight on f3
right we said if we would like to
develop our pieces and that the knight
is going to attack the pawn okay so the
best move for black is actually
defending the pawn right now but again
as we said your opponent is just going
to copy from you okay so how do we
punish him what do we do now what kind
of move should Y do here who knows yes
take the pawn slip on right well almost
free and I like free stuff we're just
gonna take him yeah me Ali okay so
obviously he is going to take us as well
now it's a little bit more complicated
in this position looks like everything
is even but now wife has a very very
strong move that I would like you to
know so let's see who has an area yes
for okay so you're saying Queen to g4
okay anybody has any other idea we're
gonna look at the your idea yes II Queen
- II - excellent
all right anybody has any other idea yes
Queen to f3 also an excellent move okay
it looks like the queen is the winner
but we really have to decide where do we
put the Queen you have another idea
e - all right wait wait wait okay so now
first question is where to put the Queen
now all those moves on are good now if
we play Queen - G for the Queen from
here is attacking the knight what is the
best defense here for full black who
knows what's the best defense here let's
see this one move is very very good as a
hint I'm going to tell you that black
can defend his Knight but he can also
attack the Queen and there are actually
two moves like that yes
excellent very good pawn to d5 is the
first one defending the knight and
attacking the Queen all right and the
other move black and also probably play
just Knight to f6 just escaped with the
ninth defending the knight and attacking
the Queen from here
okay so cling to g4 is not as good Queen
to f3 is very tricky because if we
defend the knight now let's say the pawn
goes to d5 what can I do here yes Queen
takes f7 checkmate exactly very very
good as you can see the knight is
defending the Queen and it was a very
very fast win but in here black can
actually defend form the threat pretty
easy how is that yeah yeah yeah you can
play either Knight of 6 oops again or 95
attacking the Queen and defending or
even Knight to d6
okay so Queen after it looks good but
not as powerful as Queen to d2
Queen to d2 is the best move so let
let's think about now first of all we
said that the black is going to copycat
right but if black plays Queen to e7 you
take the night and if it takes all night
yeah you guys just gonna laugh in his
face right and then you're gonna take
his screen and that's it right it's not
a check rate but the King has to move or
he has to cover with the bishop and it's
a very easy win right with the Queen up
so hopefully your opponent does know
some chess so hopefully here he realizes
that Queen is seven would actually lose
the Queen now in this case black would
probably move the knight somewhere
now the knight has many spots he can go
to c5 d 6f 6 g5 so these are the main
main options but let's just look at one
of them that's it's just the knight goes
back to f6 well he came from now it
looks like black has successfully
defended his position right but wife has
a very very strong move again and which
allows him to win the black queen so
what is the move that white can do yes
please
okay
interesting you're saying Knight takes
f7 now first of all good idea because
it's a check and also the knight is
attacking the Queen and the rook the
knight is forking the Queen and the rook
but yeah unfortunately it doesn't work
that well because the king can both go
out of the check and take the knight so
that doesn't work but very close very
close good idea you're in the right
direction but it needs just some kind of
improvement somebody I didn't hear
before yes
no I could see six very good now in the
chess game we call it a discovered check
okay so actually not the piece who just
moved made a check but is the piece
behind him okay it's what it was hiding
the Queen was hiding behind the King
I think the knight and everywhere the
night goes it is actually going to be a
check so the only question is where is
the best place for the night okay and
you guys were correct Knight to c6 is
the most powerful move now it looks like
the knight is attacked three times by
the pawns and by the night but nobody
can take it all right because it's a
check so black has to defend from the
check first and only then defend his
queen now black has two options you can
either define with the bishop but in
this case we are just going to capture
the Queen right or
he can defend with a queen and in this
case you also take the Queen okay
so this is a very very good trick to
know especially you're playing as your
classmates or maybe against your parents
which try to copycat from you okay so I
would like to suggest that you guys make
a bet with your parents okay if you beat
them you get you get a cake a candy I
can do is enough No so before we make
this trap make a bet all right but you
didn't hit it for me okay okay guys so
this is the copycat variation now you
can make it one time against somebody
but then hopefully your parents will
learn okay how to defend against it now
hey I would like to show you the next
trick on how to beat them your opponents
very very fast now this mate is very
famous because it is it's very fast okay
this is this mate we call a scalos mate
and some of you know it now the reason
what why I would like to show it to you
is a because so you know how to check
make your opponents very quickly and be
you also need to know how to defend from
the scholars mate okay so the second
move after white is playing a four a
five
the the bishop is actually going to see
four okay now technically actually this
opening has its own name it's called the
bishops opening okay like we had the
full night's opening this is called the
bishops opening now let's say black
knows how to play the four Knights
opening and he just continues with the
same
move order so Knight to c6 yeah so the
Bible when you usually play Knight to f3
usually black is playing Knight to c6
so black said okay you just develop your
Bishop there is no difference I which I
should just put my knight on c6 now
white actually develops the screen the
Queen can go either to f3 or to h5 the
h5 move is a little bit more sneaky why
is that because here suddenly black
realizes wait a second I can move my
knight to f6 attacking the White Queen
right but they have actually a very big
mistake all right
- so raise your hand
why is the mistake how can white punish
black yeah yes where on f7 who's gonna
capture the bishop Odin or the Queen I
was gonna captured yes the Queen yes and
the Queen just takes on f7 okay very
very fast this is a checkmate in only
four moves that's it you check with your
opponent and you go home all happy
so now usually it's not so good to
develop the Queen in the opening so I
would like to show you if you are
playing as black how to punish your
opponent how to defend some date for
this checkmate but also how to punish
your opponent okay now first of all the
easiest way if white starts with the
Bishop Bishop c4 the easiest way to
defend from it is what ya
Knight to f6 that is correct
now the idea is that now the knight is
controlling the h5 square also the
knight is controlling the F file so he
is blocking this mate so there is no
mate threat that's pretty easy right so
after your opponent moves the bishop out
you just have to move the other night
the knight who's attacking the pawn ok
but there is a more tricky variation of
the scalos mate and this is when white
moves the Queen first now in this case
the Queen is attacking the pawn so what
should we do now here we have two
options we have two choices there is a
risky one and there's a safer one so
let's see what are you ideas yeah what's
your idea yeah
96 okay anybody has any other idea yes
Queen I seven okay Queenie seven yes
any other ideas
yeah
Knight to e7 okay yeah on d6 d6 okay
any other ideas now first of all okay
it's a good good ideas first of all
white white expects black to do is to
make this move g6 which is a terrible
move and just because you took some
lessons with me you know that this move
is is a bit bad right
because now white is going to crash
black he's going to take on e5 and then
take his rook and then sweep all this
the eighth-ranked so g6 is a very bad
move so well how to defend first of all
we can play 96 this is the safe route
because the knight is defending the pawn
although here why I can still play this
move Bishop c4 yes and now only after
this move now you can play pawn to g6
defending attacking the Queen now the
Queen she's a bit pesky so she can still
go back and she can still threaten this
mate on f7 but here we can defend find
another defense yes 9 f6 very good this
is one of the best options actually how
to defend against the skulls made
because as we said timing chess is very
very valuable and if you can see what
why I did white spending so much time
with the screen he moved the Queen to h5
then he moved the Queen to f3 and black
is just continuing to develop his pieces
yeah so really black is apparent in
development okay so this is the safe
route now what is the risky one
show you the risky one after Queen to h5
you can actually attack the queen with
Knight to f6 okay but in this case you
are actually sacrificing this pawn on e5
check but here you can just block with
your bishop now why did why did we gain
now it looks like we just gave up upon
but we gained some time so for example
if white tries to play pawn to d4 and
says hey I have the center I have the
Queen in the middle I have a pawn up
mm-hmm
because black got the time and he'll
black and actually playing 96 and
although your queen is in the center I
have more pieces Oh which are developed
and the center becomes very very shaky
very very weak so white has to move the
Queen and he is definitely going to lose
one of those pawns okay so when you push
your pawns be careful because you want
your pieces to support those pawns you
can't just push all your pawns all alone
okay yes
yes a pawn or a queen also black is
going to castle next move and bring his
rook to e8 and start attacking the King
very very fast okay so you sacrifice a
pawn for a positional advantage sounds
good
alrighty so these are the two tricks
that I wanted to teach you but there is
another one so again we learn as far as
now we learn the copycat variation how
to punish a copycat opponents then we
learn the scalos mate let's look at
another another trap let's say you're
playing white you play efore pawn to e5
Knight f3 Knight to c6
now usually as we said white can play 93
but in this case white can you can also
play Bishop to c4 where's your hand so
what is the name of this opening yes
yeah there is the fried liver what else
there's another one
yeah no name yet there is actually a
name yeah
[Music]
the Italian yeah but the bishop on c4
it's called the Italian okay now here
black can play a few options I'm going
to show you two of them the first one is
that the black just develops is Knight
to f6 so who knows how should white
continue now yeah yeah you can play 93
okay actually 93 I'm going to show you
later how can black punish white for
this for this move 90 table there's a
stronger mobile for white yeah 95
excellent now remember that in the
openings where white starts a 45 usually
the f7 square becomes the target for the
attack becomes very very weak as you can
see white is attacking the pawn with a
bishop and with the night so how should
house a black defend yeah yeah that's
the only move right defending with the
Queen will not help because I can just
take it so pawn to d5 is the only move
pawn takes and now
what happens if the night takes on d5
that's a big big blunder you're correct
so how does white punish it looks like
black is even better right because he is
tonight in the center the Queen's is
attacking the knight but White has this
very strong sacrifice in this position
yeah not behind yes very good knight
takes f7 we sacrifice the knight King
takes and Queen to f3 I don't if the
King moves we just take the knight we
can either take with a bishop or the
Queen maybe with the bishop is better
because again we are tightening this
made on f7 if the Queen takes and Queen
takes right now if the King goes to is
six this is the only thing that we need
to know here if the King tries to
protect this Knight are we actually
going to take it no because if we
exchange all the pieces we are going to
enter into an endgame
it's kind of an endgame no Queens on the
board so although the King looks very
vulnerable in the center it is going to
be pretty safe because even if after one
check the King can just go backwards and
really we don't have enough pieces to
attack so remember this when you are
attacking your opponent you want to keep
your Queens on the board don't exchange
your Queens so how should we have played
here yes
very good 93 we usually would like to
I'd add additional force on the on the
pinned in peace okay
and this affiliation is called the fried
liver variation okay it got its name
because there was a grandmaster he said
that he said that the black is dead as a
piece of liver okay so basically a black
is losing okay with a king on his six
okay last last trapper what I wanted to
show you is that instead of knife to f6
let's say black is playing this move
pawn to d6 now the idea of pawn to d6
this is not such a good move because
it's blocking the bishop but it has
stopped the five liver because if the
knight goes to g5 now the Queen could
just take the taken right so it stopped
the fried liver so what why did 93 and
now black played Bishop to g4 everything
looks fine right up until this moment so
how to play here here it is very good to
play who was - yeah h3 very good
attacking the bishop we also call this
move a window creating a windowed for
the king that's after castle so the King
can escape the bishop escapes to h5 so
far everything you looked looks user
usual right everybody develop their
pieces black is making this nice pin but
there is a very strong move here for
white let's see if somebody can find it
so it's white to move
all right yes I think you were the first
one yeah Knight to d5
okay what's your idea let's see if I
just make nine of six almost almost
closed
was on the right direction anybody
else's any idea ideas that's a very good
sacrifice here
think about those captures yeah very
good
Adi Knight takes e5 Wow we are giving
away tonight we are giving away the
queen by giving it up everything doesn't
make any sense right but let's look what
happened in the game
black talk obviously the Queen right but
what happens here
why did the white sacrifice the Queen
because now White has a mate in two
moves a checkmate yeah
very good so it's very simple because we
just have to look for the checks the
only check that we have is Bishop takes
f7 check the king must go to e7 and
Knight going to d5 look at this the King
isn't in the center of the board but all
the squares are taking away from him
the knight takes D square and it's a
check and the King cannot take the
bishop because it is defended this is
called mate the girl okay
now what would happen if black would see
the mate and he says I'm not taking your
queen I don't know lose immediately
what if black would take the knight now
if he takes the knife with a pawn then
you just take the bishop and we we gain
a whole pawn right because we took the
pawn on e5 but the real question is what
if it takes all night with his knight
yeah yes we have to take the bishop but
now he takes a bishop uh-oh
what happened we just lost a piece I
thought that the the puzzle is working
it was supposed to be a trap
we just lost a piece how do we get the
piece back is why to move yes exactly
excellent always look for the action
moves checks captures and threats Queen
all the way is going to be 5 and
probably he has to defend and now we
take the knight
okay so this is another trap which is
coming from the Italian setup so you
have two traps which you can make you
can make other you can either make a
fried liver out of your opponent with
Knight to g5 or you can also play if he
plays d6 you can make this Knight takes
on e5 okay any questions okay so we look
at four traps today
okay the copycat variation they will
look at the skulls mate you look at my
mate the girl and the fried liver
[Music]